[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جميعا
بعرفكم عن نفسي انا عز الدين عاشور مدير
مدرسه لتعليم الموسيقى
بحب احكي لكم عن فكره المشروع اللي بديت
بالاواخر 2019 واللي هي بالرغم من بدايتها
بظرف سيء اللي هو كان ظرف كورونا الا انه
الجهد اللي بدلناه والاصرار على النجاح
الحمد لله ادى للنجاح هاي الفكره الفكره
بدات لما كنت انا بدرس موسيقى في
في بيت لحم وقسم من دراستي كان في رام
الله وكنت بصدف بعض الطلاب اللي بيجوا
لدراسه الموسيقى من الخليل السبب لانهم
كانوا بيجوا لمدن ثانيه عدم وجود مدارس او
معاهد لتعليم الموسيقى في محافظه الخليل
كنت بلمس في
التقصير انه ما في مؤسسات مهتمه بانشطه
ثقافيه بانشطه فنيه حاولت من خلال هاي
الفكره
اشتراك محافظه الخليل بالنشاط الفني
بالانشطه الثقافيه
بدينا المشروع
بال 2019 هلا مر يعني بعده مراحل اكيد
احنا بدانا بدايه صعبه ما كان في تقبل
لهاي الفكره من المجتمع في البدايه بحكم
انه في صوره نمطيه مطبوعه عند الناس عن اي
نشاط فني او اشي له علاقه بالفن او
بالموسيقى انه دائما بيتعارض مع الدين مع
عاداتنا مع تقاليدنا
كانت الفكره هاي دائما راسخه بذهني انه
لازم نعكس صوره عكس هذه الصوره يعني انه
لا بدنا نقدم الموسيقى بما يتناسب مع
عاداتنا ومع تقاليدنا ومعديلنا خصوصيه
مدينه الخليل كبلد محافظ كان لازم انه
نتماشى معها تماشينا مع هاي الخصوصيه
والحمد لله يعني كان الاشي مقلى مقنع
للناس وكان مفرح لالهم
كان في تقبل كبير وفرح كبير من اولياء
امور الطلاب
[موسيقى]
وهذا الحكي ادى لنجاح فكرتنا
هلا بالنسبه للتحديات اللي واجهناها طبعا
يعني هي كانت كثيره في تحديات اجتماعيه زي
ما حكينا انه ما كان في قبول لاي نشاط اله
علاقه بالموسيقى او بالفن بالاسباب اللي
حكينا عنها في تحديات سياسيه انه دائما
موضوع
الموسيقى في اي حدث سياسي سيء وطبعا هاي
احداث كثيره في بلدنا احنا دائما موضوع
الموسيقى بيتاثر سلبا لانه بيعتبروا انه
مش وقته احنا هلا في عنا شهداء في عنا
جرحى
فبتلاقي انه دائما في تاثير سلبي لهذه
الاحداث على موضوع الموسيقى
كان في عنا تحديات اقتصاديه انه احنا
كمؤسسه يعني
حديثين يعني باديين جديد
مش مدعومين من اي حدا يعني كان بكل تواضع
هذا جهد الشخصي كنت بعمل انه نقدر نوصل
الثقافه الموسيقيه لاكبر عدد من الناس الا
انه قدرات الناس الاقتصاديه كانت
تحول يعني بدون انه يتمكنوا من انهم
يعلموا اولادهم الثقافه الجديده هلا احنا
كمدرسه
استقبلنا عدد من الطلاب اللي شعرنا في
عندهم مواهب في هذا المجال
وما يعني من دون انهم يتكلفوا اي تكاليف
لما كنا نشعر انه هذا الطالب عنده موهبه
وبامكانه انه
يقدم شيء حلو هلا كنا نستعمله ولكن للاسف
يعني امكانياتنا كانت محدوده لجانا لكثير
مؤسسات
يعني محافظه الخليل بلديه الخليل غرفه
التجاره في الخليل
للاسف ما لقينا في قبول من هاي المؤسسات
استمريت بجهد الشخصي لليوم
وبالرغم من هذه الصعوبات كلها انا مستمر
وعندي رساله وبدي اقضيها وامل انه اقدر
استمر في اداء هذه الرساله بالرغم من كل
هذه الصعوبات شكرا لالكم يعطيكم الف عافيه